sorry fine now you're not even excited
about me it's Coachella that's what it
is right it kicks off this weekend just
just what America needs another reason
to take drugs no Coachella last two
weekends like a cabinet member who works
for Trump and it's pricey
none of that Woodstock come in for free
[ __ ] good but you got a lot for your
money I mean dozens of Acts there who
are competing for the affection of
entitled Millennials I'm sorry I'm
thinking of the Democratic primary I'm
sorry
oh yeah know that competition is on you
know who's blowing up on the polls mayor
Pete you just see that way he made a he
made a I'm proud to be gay speech and
this is red meat to the Liberals they
look that's that's your joke in your
head I wasn't even going for that but no
the battle for the heart to the
Democratic base is on I mean who Leon
Castro is a Latino and Kamala Harris is
biracial and Beto played in a punk band
and Mayor Pete's like I'm gay mic drop
so Monday is tax day or as Trump calls
it Monday yes as we're all paying ours
he will not release his you know the IRS
was supposed to get they were supposed
to get his tax returns this Wednesday
didn't happen didn't happen you know
there are committees in Congress that
are allowed by law to request any tax
returns the IRS they have to provide
them this is what we used to call a law
we don't have those anymore
Trump finally has the Lackey Attorney
General he always wanted William Bar he
testified before Congress this week he
began by thanking the committee for the
opportunity to come there and shed more
darkness on the situation this was a bad
sign when he took the oath he raised his
hand the Sharpie was still in his hand I
don't but then he then he threw a
bombshell in there he said that there
was spying or he thought there might be
spying spying on the Trump campaign Wow
the Trump campaign spot you know this is
interesting in the Trump White House
they don't do evidence so he's moving
forward with investigating the
investigators Wow can the rest of us do
that can the rest of us do that with law
enforcement if a cop stops me can I be
like how fast was I going how fast were
you going
and why are you following me I'm gonna
need to see all your text messages
officer so no to recap this okay here's
what's going on two years ago at the
beginning of the Trump administration
remember Trump was tweeting about Obama
is what was wiretapping me a Trump Tower
and of course you know everybody thought
okay it's just the more honest police
[ __ ] out of his ass nothing new nothing
to see here so you know the Justice
Department looked into it at the time
and of course found no evidence now the
Attorney General in the United States
without evidence is going to have his
Justice Department look into the Justice
Department their old investigation which
found no evidence but does anyone have
the number for Michael Jackson's doctor
I need it now
[Applause]
so Trump spent the week firing people
who aren't tough enough on migrants
Kirsten Nielsen the Caged lady she was
not tough enough she got fired although
she said they weren't fighting she said
she just wanted to spend more time
separating her family
and unless this today
they came up with a new idea why don't
we take all the migrants that we get at
the border and dump them in sanctuary
cities Wow
this Trump is not playing he said it
again today he does not want an America
of low-skilled immigrants and Melania
said [ __ ] you too I mean the the main
attitude on Fox and Friends did you see
this they called I think we have the
picture Central America Mexican
countries Mexican countries by the way
they also once called a couple weeks ago
a selfie a sea life
they even misspelled spelling bee that's
true you know what if you guys are gonna
live in the United States learn the
[ __ ] language okay this is this is
where we are right now as a country if
the Democrats don't see it your way
dump refugees in their city because
we're the United States I know we're not
supposed to use words like deplorable
hard
it's pretty [ __ ] deplorable spray no
more answers say deplorable I'm supposed
to say races I suppose face stupid
backwards hard for me lat last week this
is not a joke last week Kentucky
outlawed bestiality
[Applause]
last week and that's not even what blew
my mind the most it was the words that
began the third paragraph the article I
was reading which said opponents of the
bill
you